Papua New Guinea is home to the
saltwater crocodile the largest croc on
earth these waters a prime real estate
for hunting and meeting this female croc
patrols her territory a younger female
moves to challenge her
[Music]
their turf wars short the trespasser has
been driven off
the commotion attracts a large male this
is his territory too
[Music]
female croc sometimes take the lead in
courtship
this one rubs the male snout then blows
bubbles under his sensitive jaw she's
got his attention now he takes the lead
with a raise snout she signals
submission to avoid attack now she
slides beneath him
they mate
and when it's over a separate lane